well the site of the route 91 festival
remains fenced off memorial plans are
still underway for a portion of it while
the remainder could be used for
something else christian joins us live
in studio with an update and on why
construction hasn't begun just yet
christian well kirsten as you can
imagine it's been a very long process
and according to the las vegas
resiliency center the community is
heavily involved in what
they want to get there because they tell
us that they want to make sure that it
is perfect now the mgm resorts
international announced their donation
of two acres of property for the
memorial site back in august and we
spoke to the las vegas resiliency center
today and they tell us the site has not
been touched they understand there are
different emotions from the community
about what the land should be used for
now the land is private property but
they tell us the donated land will
reflect a community approved memorial
so we don't know what the memorial looks
like yet and we've got a gathered a lot
of information from the community on the
different things that they would like to
be incorporated into that memorial
and we haven't engaged the
arts architectural
world
yet well mgm tells us event parking is
planned for near-term use of the site
but those plans have not been
established now again no memorial design
has been set for the site that process
is set to begin later this month
christian gossett is 8 news now